we're very excited by Easter raise
insecure co-stars react to her rumoured
engagement we all found out her ways
because we all know different text
change and talk at different times so we
all found out the reaction was all the
same like the rumors surfaced last week
that the 34 year old actress was engaged
for longtime boyfriend after her essence
magazine cover was released showing off
a gorgeous sparkler on that finger this
exceeds everyone's expectations Jay also
opened up about his new film Top Gun
maverick which he stars in alongside Tom
Cruise it's gonna be an amazing movie
you know tom is tom is that dude and so
you know that tom is like literally
gonna make sure that we go there you
know we've been filming for about six
months now we got a few more to go and
it's been an amazing ride Tom's been a
mentor Joe Kosinski our directors been
amazing Jerry Bruckheimer has been
amazing the whole cast is dope it's it's
amazing it's gonna say right now it's
gonna be we are going to literally blow
people's minds
[Music]
[Applause]